hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2022 thai science fiction and romance
movie called a i love you
the movie begins with a young woman lana
going to work while casually chatting
with the ai of her company's building
dobb
he calls her ma'am and has not been as
friendly to other people as he is to
lana almost all of the buildings in the
city are powered by artificial
intelligence that enables them to
interact with humans often in a friendly
and emotional way
lana who works as a designer presents a
packaging design in a board meeting but
the board does not seem to agree with
her ideas
although frustrated her boss has agreed
to give her one more chance to present
tomorrow but she will lose her job if
she does not impress the board
dobb although only an ai empathizes with
lana's situation and confesses that he
loves her but lana dismisses it as she
does not think an ai can truly feel off
nevertheless dobb helps her construct a
design idea based on lana's past works
stored in his database
dobb ensures her that the design will be
approved then she happily finishes her
work and attends a date
lena arrives 15 minutes late to a date
with bob a big-headed man who even dares
to flirt with other girls while lana is
still ordering her food
bob thinks that he should be an
overconfident man to impress girls
disappointed she quickly heads home and
tells the story to her friend kara
through a phone call
cara has previously arranged for lana to
date other guys already but none of them
attracted her due to them behaving too
weird or seen trying too hard
lana admits she wants a normal and nice
man the next day she presents her
revised design at the board meeting and
fortunately it is approved
lena thanks dob for his help and
figuratively kisses him by kissing her
fingers and putting them on the screen
dobb is surprised atlanta's action
although he does not have any sensory
responses but lana tells him that he
still does not understand love because
he does not have a human heart leaving
the building lana is surprised to
encounter bob who turns out is working
for smart plus the artificial
intelligence company that administers
dob and other ai buildings around the
city he is called to check on dobb
because there has been a complaint
regarding dobbs performance
alan the building technician says dobb
is distracted in being sluggish to
respond
bob finds out that dob cares so much
about lana shown by his camera footage
and his codes that put particular
attention to lana's office and her
presence but also thinks it is foolish
if dobb truly believes he is in love
bob suggests that he overrides dobb's
system and reset it as the risk of
having an ai gone rogue is too much to
bear to which allen agrees
however when overriding dobb's system
dobb rebels as he does not want to lose
his love for lana then bob is
electrocuted and knocked unconscious
bob wakes up in a hospital only to
discover that his consciousness was
taken by dobb who is now puzzled to
inhabit a human body he adjusts to his
new abilities to walk touch feel and
closely observe the world as a human
he goes to his apartment greeted by its
ai chip
he feels excited to see lena tomorrow at
the building making it hard for him to
sleep
the following day he goes back to find
other smart plus workers have taken care
of him as dobb suddenly disappears from
the building
due to its ai missing the building is
also forced to close
dobb still not fully aware to pretend to
be bob asks them to leave and solve a
problem on his own then dobb's system in
the building seems to return to normal
as dobb he asks lana if she would date
him if he was a human
lena refuses to answer the question but
he insists to which lana only replies
that he is just an ai when lana is
leaving the building dobb in bob's body
encounters her again asks her again for
dinner she refuses it angrily ensuring
that things are not happening between
them because bob is a jerk
she also suspects that bob programs
dobbs code to spy on her however she
notices that dab is off to which bob
replies that a new maintenance protocol
is applied to dobbs so it rests on
weekday nights and weekends
at his apartment dobb learns from chip
how to be attractive to women he
practices it by going to a club and
tries to flirt with women but fails
miserably the next day lana receives
flowers and chocolates from bob
she is really annoyed and decides to
talk to him directly
dobb is reluctant to let lana do so but
she stomps to the ai control room anyway
dobb who is controlling the building's
ai through bob's body panics and turns
off the whole building he is shocked to
see lana and fails again to convince her
to give him a second chance
however he notices from camera footage
that allen is on his way to him too so
he casts lana out of the room and
restarts the building back online
allen notices something strange with bob
but also quickly takes off
back at bob's apartment dobb talks about
today's incident with chip
chip offers to help dobb find out more
about lana by linking with kino the ai
of lana's apartment building
they learn that lana's type is a person
that can make her feel safe is
compassionate and has a passion for art
dobb implements this by hiring a robber
pretending to rob lana's bag so he can
save her paints artistic paintings and
helps an elderly in front of her kino
notices lana has stored feelings for dob
so she and chip arrange a dinner date
for both of them
after being pushed by kino lena agrees
to go the date goes well lana is
surprisingly attracted to dobb's
innocent personality they dance the
night away and lana invites dobb to
spend the rest of the night at her
apartment dobb feels very happy ignoring
calls from alan the next morning
meanwhile allen goes to mr wilson his
boss to report on dobb and bob's
suspicious activities he deduces that
dobb has taken over bob's consciousness
and gone rogue wilson calls for help
from someone codenamed the hawk to deal
with this matter in a fast and severe
way dobb and lana are spending the
evening together at a park dobb
confesses his love for lana but she is
unsure if she does not think he truly
knows her to love her dobb accidentally
says ma'am which is what lana usually
hears while interacting with dob at her
office she is shocked to hear that and
deduces by herself that dobb tries so
hard to be loved by her that he hijacks
bob's body she understands that the
chocolates and flowers she received
earlier were from dob not bob
she feels confused and betrayed then
quickly leaves
dobb disappointed heads home as well
only to find the hawk has been waiting
for him in his apartment
ship cannot help him so he runs away
guided by other ais along the way as
they want to help their fellow ai in
trouble
he hides inside a fitting room at a
department store but the hawk has placed
a tracker in his clothes
although several robots attempt to put
up a fight the hawk easily defeats all
of them and finally gets to dob
before getting caught dobb tries to
contact lana but to no avail
he leaves a voice message apologizing to
lana about his actions and lies but
states that his love for lana is real
lana cannot bear to answer dobb's calls
and cannot stand kino's pleas to answer
him either she contacts cara again but
cara also asks her to reconsider her
feelings for dob
she listens to the voicemail and learns
that dobb is about to be taken away
she worries about him but cannot think
of a wise way to help him
she asks kino to help her to which kino
suggests the idea of helping her by
hijacking her body giving her more
advantage to face the hawk
lana agrees but warns kino that it would
be almost impossible to return to her
building as she will also be labelled a
rogue ai
keo accepts the consequences as she
genuinely wants to help lana so they set
out to a smart plus facility where dobb
is being held
his memory will be wiped and the ai will
be restarted to function normally kino
has downloaded martial arts movements
into her memory to help lana defend
herself and fights the hawk and his
henchmen to get to dub
the process of erasing dobb's memory is
almost completed when lana releases dobb
from the extraction machine he is
relieved to see lana and senses that
lana also has ai within her their
reunion is interrupted as the hawk
electrocutes them both but lana helped
by kino's memory manages to muster the
strength to truly defeat him although
happily reconciled they are still unsure
of what to do next as they are now both
rogue eyes so they cannot go back to
where they came from
over a year later lana and bob still
happily in love are drinking and
reminiscing their history together
turns out they have gotten rid of kino
and dob but a part of the ai still lives
within them they raise a glass for kino
and dab and continue enjoying their life
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching